this animated series about nfts may be
cancelled after its main character
aboard ape was stolen the announcement
came at v-con which if you don't know is
where a bunch of influencers gather
together to worship gary v and one of
the speakers this guy seth green came to
show off his world premiere trailer of a
show
about nfts whose main character is in
nft this show features seth green's
board ape as the hero of the story a
crying monkey named fred simeon now i
can't play the whole trailer because
they have some copyrighted music that's
going to be claimed in a micro second
but let me describe it to you it's a
bunch of nfts in a bar with humans it's
kind of awkward and not in a funny way i
mean i get they're going for a mix of
real life and cartoons but i can't take
your show seriously when one of your
characters has aetherium for eyes not to
mention their love interest is about as
believable as the couples in 90 day
fiance but there was one part of it that
got a chuckle out of me and that's when
gary v appeared on screen pretending to
be a human hey gary
i too frequent pubs often fellow kids
anyways as soon as the trailer ends seth
green reveals that there's a bit of a
problem a few days before he'd actually
had his main character stolen from his
crypto wallet or as he says fred was
kidnapped july 21
and
have spent the last several months
developing and exploiting the ip
to make it into
the star of this show and then
days before
his name is fred by the way
days before he said to make his
world debut he's literally kidnapped
now i don't understand why the crowd is
laughing here at seth losing his main
character because this is actually a
really big deal the show is possible
because he owns the board ape nft see
every board ape nft comes with a
commercial art license that is it allows
the owner to create sort of anything
they want shoes clothing even tv shows
with that character now what this means
though is that when the thief stole this
nft they also stole those ip rights
meaning seth green is no longer the
owner of those commercial rights which
makes his show kind of illegal and this
whole thing is so ironic because that's
the whole pitch of nfts isn't it like
you truly own something you possess it
but if a scammer steals it from you in
what sense do you now own it it isn't
clear especially since that bored ape
that seth owned has now been sold on the
secondary market to somebody by the name
of
darkwing84 seth green has tried to reach
them on twitter saying quote looks like
you bought my stolen ape hit me up so we
can fix it now darkwing hasn't responded
to this and technically until he does
he's the real owner of these commercial
use rights not seth green and all seth
can do is tell people he's going to make
those scammers pay saying he's going to
kick down any door he has to to recover
this nft if there's a door to kick in
but let's be honest with ourselves the
only thing seth is going to be kicking
is himself because i'm going to tell you
guys right now
not much of a chance they find this guy
even though seth green says he has the
best people on the case uh i'm already
into
the best authorities that you can get
i've got the um
the means to be able to chase this a
little bit it's a matter of whether that
where it is a person there's some
foreign financial conglomerate or some
massive
scam house somewhere we'll figure it out
i got something
on the job
now of course i don't know who this
crack squad of crypto investigators are
maybe they hired liam neeson to find the
hackers i don't know but in my
experience the first thing most
investigators are going to tell you is
that the only way to track down hacks
like this is if the scammer kind of
makes a mistake i mean it's possible to
track down the wallet you know where the
stolen nft went of course but finding
the actual people behind it
is nearly impossible in a lot of these
cases so yeah seth green probably isn't
getting his nft back any time soon
unless he pays for it and hopefully
isn't extorted until then his crypto nft
show looks like it's probably on hold
which honestly may be for the better i
mean i'm sorry to seth green i'm sorry
that happened to him but for the world
for humanity i think it might be overall
a good thing just me personally i guess
i don't like shows built around nfts
kind of for the same reason i don't like
the minions movie
it's a whole piece of art built around
only selling you some kind of stupid
cartoon figure at higher and higher
prices like
don't get me wrong i get it art has to
make money sure but when the entire
purpose of the thing is to make the
price go up go to the moon
it's just never that interesting the
only real difference i can see between
this new show that was going to come out
and like those hacky merch movies is
just really that when you buy a minions
plushie and it gets stolen you lose 10
bucks if you're seth green and you lose
your board ape you lose hundreds of
thousands and you might lose your tv
show anyways that's basically all i
wanted to talk about see ya